[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys welt
ich möchte euch heute meinen super
genialen schokokuchen vorstellen und
zwar ist es der schoko teig bin ich
immer ganz gerne benutzen wenn ich motiv
torten machen
dieser tag ist von der konsistenz her
fest aber sehr saftig sehr schokoladig
und ich kann ihn vor allen dingen auch
gut vorbereiten und ich bin zum beispiel
auch ganz gerne nicht nur für normale
motiv torten sondern auch für die torten
dich zu schneiden musste zum beispiel 3d
torten und ich zeige euch jetzt einmal
kurz die zutaten
ich habe hier 320 gramm butter 200
bitterschokolade 250 gramm zucker 8 390
kamel 30 gramm kakaopulver 15 teelöffel
backpulver etwas vanille und salz und es
geht jetzt auch ganz schnell ihr braucht
keine küchenmaschine der teig ist doch
super schnell gemacht und zwar gibt
jetzt zuerst die butter in einen kleinen
topf und stellt den topf auf mittlere
hitze
jetzt lasse ich die butter erst mal so
ein bisschen zerlassen und gleich dann
noch die schokolade und ein damit sich
das alles schön auflöst aber soll halt
nicht heiß werden sondern soll sich nur
kurz auflösen
[Musik]
so sieht die masse jetzt aussieht ist
nicht heiß sondern nur warm und ich kann
jetzt schon mal hier in einer
rührschüssel die eier verrühren mache
ich jetzt auch mit dem schneebesen mit
dem gleichen da gebe ich auch den zucker
mit rein und auch eine prise salz und
etwas vanille extrakt
und jetzt gehe ich hier langsam die
schokolade mit rein und verrührt es
einfach schön mit dem bruder
[Musik]
sie kann ich jetzt mal die trockenen
zutaten vermischen also mehl backpulver
und kakaopulver und da nimm dir bitte
richtiges kakaopulver also kein cover
band cover enthält ja sehr viel zucker
und das richtige kakaopulver schmeckt
eben richtig schokoladig
und die trockenen zutaten kommen jetzt
auch mit zu einer schoko mischung mit
rein und werden jetzt noch mal schnell
verrührt
[Musik]
und den teig verteile ich jetzt in meine
vorbereitete backformen ich habe zwei
bad haben mit 20 cm durchmesser beide
auch schon mit backpapier eingeschlagen
wenn ihr jetzt diesen tag machen wollt
für eine andere backform geht ihr
einfach auf meinen blog sallis - blog.de
und dann schreibe ich euch da die
umrechnung tabelle mit ein denn dann
könnt ihr einfach die zutaten für eine
größere form wie zb eine 26 zentimeter
vom einfach um rechnen wobei motiv dort
ist es so die sollen jetzt ziemlich hoch
werden und deswegen backe ich diesen tag
lieber in zwei schritten also in zwei
formen
dann wagt doch schön gleichmäßig und
wird einfach etwas schön und ich backe
beide teig bei ober und unterhitze 160
grad für ungefähr 35 minuten wenn ihr
eine größere form habt backt natürlich
den gesprächen länger die beiden bösen
sind jetzt gebacken und nach dem backen
könnt ihr auch direkt wenn sie noch im
ofen sind die stäbchen probe machen
das heißt ich nehme zahnstocher oder
einen schaschlikspieß und stelle ich
ihnen ein höchst ihnen die höchste
stelle des kuchens am besten mit ich und
wenn dann nichts mehr dran klebt ist der
kuchen fertig hier sehen sie noch 23
krümmel dran die sind jetzt nicht
schlimm
das kommt daher dass der kuchen eben
auch schön saftig ist und ich habe die
zwei kuchen jetzt schon mal auf so ein
abkühlen gitter gestellt und löst hier
den torten rahmen dann können sie
nämlich richtig schön gleichmäßig
abkühlen
[Musik]
zum abkühlen lege ich da noch ein
sauberes geschirr tuch drüber und lassen
jetzt erst mal komplett abkühlen und
anschließend das habe ich jetzt hier
auch schon vorbereitet wenn ich gleich
noch weiter backen könnt ihr sie dann
auch bewahren zb im sommer totenglocke
und dann können das auch in den
kühlschrank geben im kühlschrank wird
der kuchen auch etwas fester und zum
beispiel für motiv torten daneben etwas
stabiler
das heißt wenn ich jetzt den kuchen für
eine motiv torte benutzen möchte dass
ich in einen tag im kühlschrank holen
am nächsten tag ist er an super und ich
kann ihn perfekt weiterverarbeiten und
ihr könnt dieses rezept gerne auch noch
mal nachlesen auf see lease back de und
ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß dabei
jetzt da sie es
[Musik]